le collège national des gynécologues
obstétriciens que j'ai présidée jusqu'à
la semaine dernière
c'est effectivement préoccupée depuis
très longtemps de ce sujet notre
discipline gynécologie obstétrique est
devenu tellement énorme que plus
personne ne peut la maîtriser tout seul
et donc elle se décompose en plusieurs
parties une partie qui est très visible
et l'obstétrique c'est-à-dire
l'accouchement le suivi de grossesse il
ya une partie qui est la gynécologie où
il ya une partie chirurgicale et une
partie médicale et c'est isabelle héron
qui parlera de la partie médicale de la
gynécologie
une partie qui est leur taux génique est
extrêmement importante
la contraception et liv et g et il ya
une partie nouvelle qui est la
reproduction la m
bien entendu l'analyse que je peux faire
n'est pas la même selon les souches à
pitre si vous le voulez bien je vais
tout d'abord vous parler de la manière
dont nous voyons l'obstétrique
c'est-à-dire l'accouchement
il y a depuis très longtemps dans les
structures du ministère de la santé une
analyse de la répartition des maternités
parce que c'est ça même fille dans les
faits divers lorsqu'on ferme une
maternité parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'obstacle siens pour la chaire et ça
peut donner des accidents et même des
accidents fort grave une espèce de rag
s'y dégage et faire en sorte qu'aucune
femme ne soit à plus de 45 minutes en
hiver d'un lieu d'accouchement sécurisé
ceci est pratiquement le cas à 98% il y
a encore qu'on appellerait des déserts
médicaux ou des zones ou en hiver par
exemple dans les salles on est à plus de
45 minutes d'un lieu de l'accouchement
la manière non la spécialité que la
spécialité propose pour ce problème
savait qu'on a un nombre restreint de
nouveau de nouveaux obstétriciens et
quand vous proposer un jeune d'aller
dans un petit pays où
il aura un accouchement tous les
trois-quatre jours et où il aura du mal
à mettre ses enfants à l'école il ya une
une réalité tangible c'est qu'avec la
liberté d'installation
les jeunes ne veulent plus y aller il
préfère être le 10e dans une équipe de
neuf que le troisième dans une équipe de
deux et il faut tenir compte de cela
sauf contrainte que nous ne savons pas
faire dans le pays et que d'ailleurs je
ne souhaite pas on ne mettra pas un
obstétricien à la mûre
parce que le dernier qui a été et est de
gains 365 jours sur 365
et au bout de trois ans qu'il appelait à
l'aide pour trouver un remplaçant
même un remplaçant il ne trouvait pas et
donc tout d'un coup il a dit ben y'a pas
de remplaçant je m'en vais et donc on
est confronté à cela et la discipline
propose de mettre dans ces endroits
un petit peu reculer ce que nous
appelons des centre périnatal de
proximité
de quoi s'agit-il et nous sommes
favorables à l'écriture d'une charte
pour pas que ce soit un pis-aller
quelque chose de pas valable pour les
femmes c'est un endroit où plusieurs
sages femmes couvrent le nycthémère
c'est à dire qu'il ya toujours une sage
femme présente h24 des sages femmes
choisies et diplômé en échographie
locales puissent faire le suivi de
grossesse le suivi échographique et
participer à l'activité d'orthogénie
nous proposons que c'est centre
périnatal de proximité soit dotée d'un
clic pour accoucher en urgence et il
s'agit pas de créer des petites
maternités à dix accouchements par an il
s'agit de faire en sorte qu'une femme
qui arrive à 10 natation complète dans
un centre périnatal de proximité
puissent être accueillis par la
sage-femme et accoucher sur place et non
pas mise dans une ambulance pour
accoucher dans l'ambulance
donc cette charte que nous proposons que
nous avons déjà proposé au ministère de
la santé de créer des centre périnatal
de proximité avec des sages femmes qui
souhaitent en connexion avec l'hôpital
local doté d'une maternité
et des sages-femmes qui aurait une ligne
privilégié pour pouvoir téléphoner un
praticien hospitalier responsable avec
lequel elle sera appliquée à travailler
c'est centre périnatal de proximité
nécessite également pour qu'il soit
complet un système de transport en
ambulance
qu'ils soient pris en charge par la
collectivité et donc du point de vue de
l'observer la solution nous paraît être
double celle que je viens de dire centre
périnatal de proximité et dans certains
endroits de m un hôtel hospitalier à
portée de main de la maternité où les
femmes puissent venir éventuellement
avec leurs familles avec leurs enfants
pour les quelques jours de fin de
grossesse lorsque le déplacement par
exemple en hiver et non envisageable
bien certain nombre de régions et un
certain nombre d'endroits où il faudrait
non seulement des centre périnatal de
proximité de qualité et pas n'importe
quoi mais également un hôtel hospitalier
où les femmes pourraient avec leur
famille venir passer les derniers jours
de grossesse vous savez on a un exemple
qui est la polynésie française
polynésie à près d'un millier d'îles
habitées dont certaines sont à plus
d'une heure d'avion de tahiti et
personne n'a couche sur ces îles
les femmes sont emmenés par avion
parfois avec leurs familles vers un
hôtel hospitalier qui se trouve à tahiti
dans l'enceinte de l'hôpital et elle ne
touche pas les allocations familiales si
elles repartent retour après
l'accouchement avant que les tests
correct n'était effets sur les enfants
les deux fêtes cette répartition la
combine et 6 à la taille de l'europe
c'est 2500 km de diamètre
on ne peut pas dire qu'on n'est pas des
modèles sous les yeux et des modèles qui
fonctionnent donc pour moi soit enfin
l'habitat proximité proximité c'est dans
la demi-heure en hiver d'une maternité
soit télé à distance du maintien du pied
et là il faut qu'elle ait accepte un
centre périnatal de proximité avec des
sages-femmes cap et c'est à dire diplômé
en échographie
habilitée à travailler dans ces centres
et faisant un espèce de tour de rôle
pour qu'il y en ait une h 24 sur place
avec un système de transport adapté et
parfois un hôtel hospitalier dans
l'hôpital qui a que ces femmes avec un
praticien référent capable de répondre
au téléphone ou par une garde lorsque
une sage femme a besoin d' aide parce
qu'elles se trouvent confrontés une
pathologie et qu'elle a besoin de se
concerter et tout le monde dans notre
discipline plus on se concerte plus la
qualité des soins est élevé et donc pour
moi l'obstétrique c'est les deux outils
que je viens de vous dire des centre
périnatal de proximité de qualité pas
n'importe quoi
un hôtel hospitalier dans certains
endroits
pris en charge par la collectivité et un
système 2 d'ambulances médicalisées
entre les deux pour la gynécologie je ne
parlerai que de la gynécologie fiant aux
chicanes la gynécologie chirurgicale
comme les autres disciplines
chirurgicale est en train de voir ses
effectifs ça baissier et ça tombe bien
parce qu'on opère de moins en moins on
est dans une période désescalade
thérapeutique où il ya besoin de moins
de chiens cependant le domaine de la
chirurgie s'est étendue et par exemple
un chirurgien de l'endométriose peut
n'avoir pas une grande compétence en
matière de chirurgie l'incompétent de
l'incontinence et un médecin qui fait de
la chirurgie d'incontinence peut ne pas
avoir une grande compétence en matière
de chirurgie de la reproduction et de la
stérilité
ce qui fait que les outils dont nous
avons besoin pour soigner les femmes au
niveau de compétence qu'elle exige en
matière de chirurgie sont forcément des
grands services qui regroupe toutes les
sous discipline de la chirurgie
gynécologique quelqu'un qui n'opère que
très peu d'incontinence urinaire mauvais
quand ils en opéra deux parents et
chacun d'entre nous préfèrent être opéré
pour son cancer du sein par un praticien
qui en opère plus de 100 par an plutôt
que par un praticien qui a ouvert deux
parents cet effet un effet de
concentration pour la chirurgie
gynécologique
je suis favorable grands centres de
chirurgie gynécologique et à ce titre le
collège a proposé pour l'endométriose
savait que on a un problème un peu
historique avec tant de mes trios
on est en ad tech le site tardif mais
pas parce qu'on veut pas les diagnostics
et parce que c'est difficile à
diagnostiquer parce que il y a beaucoup
de symptômes qui peuvent apparaître
comme normaux à certains et qui ne sont
pas normaux pour d'autres bref
l'endométriose est en train de
s'organiser dans notre pays en systèmes
de grappes avec un centre référent
un staff pour tous les et pour éviter
que des femmes ne soit opéré par un
chirurgien de l'endométriose quant au
père 3 par an parce que son store être
obligés d'y retourner avec toutes les
complications et toute la mauvaise
qualité vouloir faire en sorte qu'un
chirurgien de l'endométriose dans chaque
petite ville c'est abaisser le niveau de
compétences auxquelles les femmes seront
exposés et donc ce que nous proposons
mais nous n'avons pas encore été suivie
par ministère c'est un 30/1 centre
expert par région avec une grappe de
centre connecter à ce centre expert pour
que tous les cas soit staff et en commun
donc chirurgie gynécologique je lui a
très très vraiment différemment de
l'obstétrique autant l'obstétrique et
fauqué du monde partout entre
l'électricien le sage femme
autant pour la chirurgie gynécologique
je trouve que c'est pas bien d'exposer
des femmes un chirurgien qui opère de
cancer du sein pas en parce qu'il n'aura
pas la compétence et que les sont
introduits ne seront pas les bons sur
l'île et g vous le savez comme moi il ya
deux sortes ivg et si vg médicamenteuse
et des ivg chirurgicales
nous sommes aidés et même je dirais même
plus qu'aider depuis que l'ordre des
sages-femmes à accepter l'idée de
participer vous ivg il ya une vingtaine
d'années les ivg médicamenteuses sont
très largement cette et de qualité par
les sages-femmes et j'allais même dire
presque
quel que soit l'âge gestationnel les
sages femmes ont appris à gérer
l'analgésie de ces ivg
et pour moi le la solution de
l'orthogénie sait que dans les centres
dont je viens de parler les centre
périnatal de proximité
les sages-femmes cap et dont je parlerai
c'est à dire des sages-femmes qui est un
parcours non seulement des convertis
mais également de génie soit capable de
gérer sur place les ivg médicamenteuses
car on ne peut pas demander à une femme
d'aller faire 100 km pour son évêché
donc ivg médicamenteuses je vous le
rappelle représente actuellement
mais ce pourcentage est en augmentation
depuis 20 ans 70 % des ivg de notre pays
n'y a plus que 30 % des ivg
chirurgicales
néanmoins notre collège a opté pour le
fait que les femmes puissent toujours
choisir entre ivg médicamenteuses ivg
chirurgicales et je pense qu'une femme
qui demanderaient et il y en aura de
moins en moins une ivg chirurgicales
quel que soit l'âge gestationnel soit
orientée vers le centre vers la
maternité la plus proche et la plupart
des maternités y compris les petites
maternités ont un centre diverger mais
il faut également une salle d'opération
pour ces ivg chirurgicales
il faut également un anesthésiste et
donc je distingue donc dans l'activité
d'orthogénie le gros des ivg 70% qui
peuvent être faites localement en
ruralité et une petite proportion de
femmes qui souhaitent être endormi pour
leur ivg chirurgicales et ces femmes là
on prendra alors un rendez vous par le
réseau de soins créée entre le centre
périnatal de proximité et le l'hôpital
référente quoi dernier point c'est la mp
je ne suis pas favorable à ce que chacun
est un centre dan paix en bas de chez
soi
la npa exige des laboratoires elle exige
des compétences
il y à une centaine de centres d'accueil
paix dans notre pays qui fonctionne très
bien et créer des centres
supplémentaires de mp s'est éparpillé
les moyens pour faire en sorte que une
femme et un peu moins
trajet à faire il faut donc regarder à
nouveau la carte et voir s'il ya des
endroits qui sont creux il ya un désert
médical en matière d'aep et et je pense
avec mon expérience de ce sujet qu'il ne
faut pas rajouter de centre dante dans
notre pays que la mp nécessite trop de
moyens en laboratoire ans biologiste on
est pauvre ans biologiste au moins
autant qu'on est pauvre en médecin
capable de gérer correctement la mp et
donc je suis favorable à ce que la mp
continuent d'être faits dans la centaine
de centres agréés pour ce faire je
trouve pour terminer que l'idée d'un bus
pour la santé des femmes est pas une
mauvaise idée parce que ya des endroits
où et c'est isabelle héron qui en
parlera notre pauvreté et extrêmes en
matière de gynécologie médicale dans la
ruralité elles mêmes dans les villes et
donc le fait de dire eh bien il ya un
jeune chef de clinique qui accompagne le
bus lequel bus fera une tournée des
villages pour s'occuper de la santé des
femmes
peut-être avec dans le bus une sage
femme pour l'aider je pense que c'est
pas une mauvaise idée
et ça aurait le mérite d'attirer plus de
femmes vers le dépistage et faire en
sorte que les femmes qui ne sont pas
dépistés en matière de cancer le soin un
petit peu plus dans la ruralité c'est
vrai que nous constatons des cancers
avancés chez des femmes qui ne
consultent jamais le gynécologue et une
petit événement dans le village que
constitue qui constituerait la visite du
bus gynécologique
ben ça ferait que les femmes iraient
ensemble vers ce but pour consulter un
médecin ou une sage-femme pour le
dépistage et je crois que ce serait pour
peu de frais une très bonne opportunité
voilà madame ce que je peux dire en
première approximation et bien écoutez
professeur je vous remercie beaucoup
pour déjà
tout ce que vous avez dit pas ce que
vous évoquez déjà certaines pistes
également certaines propositions donc je
vais donner immédiatement la parole au
docteur isabelle héron présidente de la
fédération nationale des collèges de
gynécologie médicale
j'aurais presque pu vous laissez faire
la transit de transition professeurs
puisque vous l'aviez évoquée merci à
vous docteur chaussettes la parole je
m'entendais bien oui c'est bien mesdames
messieurs avant de démarrer je voudrais
merci madame la présidente ne va pas
résister à cette table ronde sur la
problématique de la santé la femme en
milieu rural une problématique
extrêmement importante et je voudrais
aussi remercier le professeur israël
nisand de permettre à la fédération de
prendre part à cette réflexion parce que
on est le version le versant au médical
de la gynécologie
alors je voudrais juste faire un petit
rappel pour ceux qui connaissent pas la
fédération je vais donc présenté le 7
sociétés savantes qui est composé en
fait deux collèges régionaux en août
hal est en fait la fédération donc
fédération des collèges national de
gynécologie médicale en est l'instance
nationale les collèges vont composer
eux-mêmes dans la grande majorité de
gynécologues qui comme on a aussi eu des
médecins généralistes condé du gym est
cool s'inscrit dans le collège également
des gynéco obstétriciens et des
gynécologues médicaux en reste et
gynécologues ont un mode d'exercice
essentiellement libérale est en fête qui
fait finalement la spécificité est
l'intérêt de la fédération
c'est ce maillage territorial puisqu'on
est vraiment un implanté devient ces
collèges régionaux et ozil à l'exercice
excellement libéral essentiellement
libera qui fait qu'on a vraiment le
retour en fait de ce qui se passe sur le
terrain et en fait ça fait très
longtemps fait que nous en s'inquiètent
en fait de la désertification de
certaines zones zones et de la liste des
disparités géographiques
en matière d'accès aux soins la
fédération à la boue rôle est essentiel
la défense de la gynécologie médicale et
la valorisation de la gynécologie
médicale et on également très impliqué
sur
l'augmentation sur le lequel il de fait
d'augmenter le nombre d'alternants
gynécologie médicale pour que justement
la baisse de la démographie et quittent
actuellement crucial et on adore creux
de la vague puisse être après compensé
par le l'augmentation du nombre d'appels
et de mensah ensuite
alors en fait le gynécologue médical
comme vous le disiez très justement dans
votre introduction madame la présidente
un rôle essentiel dans la vie d'une
femme puisqu'il accompagne tout au long
de sa vie avec des périodes charnières
quelques l'adolescence qui pose le
problème la contraception dépistage des
ist de la prévention des grossesses non
désirées
ensuite il ya le désir d'enfant ou le
nom désir d'enfant avec les problèmes de
fertilité de pma éventuellement la suite
la grossesse dont je ne parlais pas
parce que le professeur nisand la
boxster et puis ensuite la ménopause et
que en fait toutes ces périodes
charnières en fait on des spécificités
qui leur sont propres et dans les mails
en fait le gynécologue centres à travers
une toute son expertise peut avoir donc
les champs d'activité sont très variés
et la gynécologie en fait on parle
beaucoup de pépi stage en fait pour moi
la gynécologie va bien au delà du
dépistage du cancer du col de l'utérus
et du sein il donc ils passent par
lorsque jenny la contraception mais la
contraception à risque
l'appréhension détester le suivi des
postes cancer le risque cardiovasculaire
quand on parle beaucoup parce qu'on sait
que les femmes consultent leurs parcs
enterrés dans des couleurs automatique
et ya un retard au diagnostic
après et avant prise en charge et on
sait très bien aussi que les femmes ont
plus de risques de mourir d'un infarctus
que les hommes donc les autres terrains
de pour lesquels morgan expertise la
production l'adema ce qui va poser
problème on parle beaucoup de la
présentation des six ter sociétale et
donc il faut que toutes les femmes aient
un accès d'information à cette
préservation aussi terre en sociétale
quel que soit le lieu où elles
s'additionnent la sexualité bien sûr la
gynéco endocrino
consiste à suivre des syndromes de
tourneur nom qu'en fait les femmes qui
soient éloignés de centres de soins
spécifique et ben en fait non pas 16 c à
ce suivi spécifique est très important
le suivi des femmes séropositives
d'oncogénétique avec la prévention qui
va être qui va être très importante en
fait temps là le temps pour la
prévention des débits télérama restée
veut redonner des cris qu'elle développe
à cancelles et puis 15 dur je terminerai
par les violences conjugales
on parle beaucoup pendant cette période
de confinement qui nous interpelle
beaucoup puisque français on vient y
augmenter pendant cette cette période
donc tout à pour dire que le gynécologue
en fait un rôle très important dans la
prise en charge de la santé de la femme
dans sa globalité
alors pour en fait j'ai sénat jeudi de
réfléchir finalement et on a bien
conscience qu'il ya un problème d'accès
aux soins dans la pluralité et en fait
on a essayé de réfléchir aux frais qui
avait en fait à l'accès aux soins
donc il ya bien sûr la baisse de la
démographie des gynécologues
il ya donc mais ça on en a déjà parlé
l'éloignement géographique c'est que les
femmes en rade accès aux soins le milieu
social défavorisé les situations de
précarité les travailleurs en situation
de précarité ne consulte pas le manque
d'informations et très probablement que
les femmes dans les milieux éloignés en
fait là de la connaissance en fait ne
savent pas qu'elles doivent consulter
qu'elle soit qu'elles doivent de faire
dépister ou qu'elles doivent de faire
suivre régulièrement donc ça je pense
que je peux développer cette information
là en tout cas qu'elles ont plus qu'aisé
plus de connaissances et puis les femmes
en fait on s'occupe bien d'elle parce
que voilà il ya les enfants d'un tamini
le travail dès que probablement elle
seule ce dell se délaisse y aussi les
peurs de consulter allez voir un
gynécologue c'est pas toujours facile
par rapport au milieu social défavorisé
par bull pour le dépistage du cancer du
col
là on a démontré qu'à peu près 40% de
fin qui échappe au dépistage
celle qui est pas chapeau dépistage chez
les femmes de plus de 50 ans donc
finalement tels qu'ils ont la rive
attraper les femmes qui sans eux qui
sont suivis pour leur grossesse ou
qu'ils consultent contraception une fois
ménopausées en fait beaucoup de femmes
ne consultent plus est celle ci échappe
au dépistage
quand elles ont des comorbidités une
obésité morbide je pense qu'elle ne soit
consulté
c'est elle qu'on inspection longue durée
et celles qui sont en situation de
handicap et de situations sociales
défavorables
bon alors qu'est ce qu'on peut proposer
en fait pour essayer de lever ces freins
à la consultation est d'amener les
femmes à consulter
puisqu'en fait dans les milieux l'oural
quand elles sont très loin quand elle
soit 80 ou 90 km d'une structure
médicale ou d'un gynécologue en fait
elles viendront pas à nous donc je pense
que c'est à nous d'aller les rênes il
faut favoriser dans un premier temps je
pense qu'il faudrait pas favoriser
l'installation ou favorisées en fait des
journées de consultations dans les zones
rurales
mais il faut pour cela il faut vous
rendiez l'activité attractive pour les
médecins se dissimuler que les médecins
allaient consulter une journée par
semaine soit dans un cabinet secondaire
parce que ça c'est intéressant soit par
exemple dans un hôpital délit felli
qu'elle proposait une journée de
consultation il faut que ce soit
attractif pour le médecin qui passe à
dire que ce soit notre activité en
matière de matériel mais aussi en
matière de valorisation financière
vous pouvez pas demander à l'inter ou en
tout cas un médecin jeunes installés ou
bien même un retraité pascal del prete
qui je pense accepterait volontiers d'
assurer des consultations si ya pas une
valorisation financière un plateau
technique qui leur permettra de
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
ce qui est important dit c'est que avec
le dépistage du cancer du col là qu'il a
démarré on va remettre de mon action
très importante des demandes de
coloscopie est donc il faut pouvoir
hum hum il va falloir quand même
proposer à sébastien à ces femmes des
axes t de consultation facile et ça ça
peut se faire tout à fait dans le temps
des dans les cabinets secondaires mais
encore faut-il avoir être au score
d'abord il avoir appris qu'il croyait
facilement alors il est bien sûr aussi
laisser piquer c'était pds ont des
structures très intéressant puisque en
fait une prise en charge optimale et
coordonnée avec les autres
professionnels de santé de la femme est
bien évidemment pas travailler de façon
coordonnée avec les sages-femmes et les
médecins généralistes ont parlé tout à
l'heure du médecin généraliste ya
beaucoup médecins généralistes qui font
la gynécologie médicale et lyon depuis
les débuts de gynécologie médicale
donc il ya des médecins généralistes une
patientèle essentiellement de deux
femmes entre callie sainte hélène et qui
sont dans le collège et qui vont à nos
journées de formation alors suivi ce
qu'on le territoire français il ya déjà
le dernier des initiatives dont il faut
s'inspirer donc en baignoire par exemple
le collège de gynécologie au travail
avec la une du rml et la cm sur les
possibilités de faire des consultations
gynécologiques avancé dans des terroirs
de santé qui ont un aspect cialis pour
satisfaire au deuxième concours est donc
possible plaide avec une salle mise à
disposition et du matériel acheté à la
commune déplacement remboursés
pourcentage supérieur sur les tarifs et
ses employés qui a déjà eu beaucoup de
choses et je pense qu'en fait on n'a pas
forcément besoin d'innover dans toutes
les régions
on peut déjà aussi s'inspirer de ce qui
est déjà fait dans les régions et qui
fonctionne alors ce qu'ils font il faut
développer des nouvelles technologies
une piste intéressante et les outils qui
sont déjà notre disposition qui est que
sur la télémédecine et la téléexpertise
et les téléconsultations on voit bien
qu'avec le coville la téléconsultation
les amputations ont explosé et dont je
pense que c'est un outil vraiment très
intéressant qui ne doit pas notamment
pour pour des avis pour des avis pour
les médecins généralistes mais aussi
pour les patientes
la téléconsultation ne doit en aucun cas
remplacer la consultation présentiel
mais c'est un outil extrêmement
important et qui nous rend vraiment
serré pour les zones blanches
dans les zones blanches où il ya un
accès internet kiné qui est très mauvais
je pense que créer des zones de coureurs
king qui permettrait de d'avoir accès à
des tu permettras tout le monde au pas
ce tient aux comptables d'avoir des
téléconsultations avec un réseau correct
ça ça paraît une piste intéressante
alors concernant la médecine intériste
en est inhérente moi j'ai suivi très
favorable il ya d'ailleurs la maximus et
maxime piste très intéressante dans
l'orne par exemple il ya ce qu'on
appelle la réclamions qui s'appelle le
mammobile qui est déjà qui existe depuis
déjà plusieurs années en fait et qui
sillonne en fait la campagne pour le
dépistage du cancer du sein
donc a priori ça fonctionne et donc à
prochainement en normandie en fait ça va
s'étendre à la normandie avec un camion
qui va qui va sillonner toute la
normandie est il là c'est une étude
randomisée qui va bien tout va bien un
jour mises en place pour être sûr qu'au
niveau coût et d'efficacité ce même en
mobilisant tous là mais la médecine at
elle est inhérente moi je trouve que
c'est une piste vraiment très
intéressante pourquoi pas éventuellement
envisager un camion d'ailleurs qui fera
la fois dépistage cancer du sein le
cancer du col et au cancer du côlon et
puis la dernière piste qui me paraissait
intéressante c'est de développer l'accès
à l'information
c'est à dire que comme disait tout à
l'heure il ya des patients qui ne savent
à des femmes qui ne savent pas qu'elles
doivent se faire suivre régulièrement ou
qui ne sépare et je pense que là des
relais locaux sont primordiaux les
relais locaux ce sont les mairies ni les
lieux de rencontre les pharmacies les
abattements sur les infirmières et
sages-femmes des médecins généralistes
entre en tout cas l'or en tout cas tout
ce que là où la patiente les femmes
entre les entraînements une information
qui leur permit qui nous permettrai de
renforts les interpeler
attention c'est vraiment important le
dépistage du principe école va démarrer
vous de valides cas dépistés etc
il faut informer les femmes de la télé
la prévention de la cosydep rhône est de
libérer leur parole
sexualité aux violences informer les
couples sur les nouvelles techniques de
procréation ne pas séparer les médecins
généralistes bien sûr les sages femmes
les infirmières propose éventuellement
des conférences et là encore en
normandie il ya un camion qui passe sur
les marchés parce qu'il sait que c'était
beaucoup plus facile en fait de faire ça
quand il fait beau sur les marchés qui
délivre en fait des flyers avec une
infirmière sage femme est en fait qui
explique en quoi consiste le dépistage
et le suivi gynécologique régulier
tu me paraît important c'est toujours
proposer des solutions pérennes avec des
interpellant fixe ça ne vous plaît pas
changé pour la gynécologie vous pouvez
pas changer
l'intervenant tous les trois mois il
faut qu'une relation de confiance qui
s'établissent entre la patiente et le
médecin pour que la patiente ait envie
d'aller voir le médecin qu'elle aura
consulté la gynéco le la conciliation de
gynécologie si une consultation très
particulière on est dans l'intimité de
la vie de femmes tout au long on a 2 rue
des recueils de beaucoup de confiance et
que si vous voulez que vraiment ce soit
les gestion efficace et qu'on se soit
vraiment dans l'intérêt de la femme
il faut que ce soit aussi des
tintamarres fixe et puis ne pas non plus
développé trop de grands dirais-je de
taxation parce que quand on démultiplie
les actions je pense qu'on est moins
efficientes et vaux bien sûr tenir
compte des disparités géographiques et
des spécificités de chaque territoire
et là en fait de s'appuyer sur les
arêtes sur les als plaisir baisse du
canadien en fait lors le paysage médical
unis servant psychologue correspond le
mieux
donc en conclusion je dirais que toutes
les femmes quel que soit leur lieu
d'habitation leurs milieux de pouvoir
bénéficier de consultations hyper
spécialisés dans le domaine de la chaîne
écologie avec une nécessité d' équité
dans l'accident l'accès aux soins
chaque professionnel de santé un rôle à
jouer et nous devons nous articuler les
1,2 à roanne le domaine de compétence
pour la tv que demanderont dernier c'est
que la fédération et je resterai encore
le professeur les avanies zande avoir de
m'avoir remplacer la fédération en fait
confrérie c'est que la fédération qui
représente la gynécologie médicale
soit un interlocuteur permanent des
décisions politiques concernant la santé
des femmes et couples les enfants à
naître puisque canton ce que bien d'une
femme
en fait on s'occupait aussi du couple et
on s'occupera aussi des enfants à naître
en demandant pouvoir participer nombreux
aux discussions mais donner aussi un à
dix contre ans fait sur les documents de
synthèse qui sont mises en place et qui
conduira des lois et des décrets et puis
d'être idéalement dans un futur plus ou
moins proche se dire que ce qui se passe
en france avec l' expertise de la
gynécologie médicale
pourquoi pas aider à rendre cette
spécialité de gm officielle a diffusé
dans les autres pays d'europe parce que
ce qu'on sait combien la gynécologie
médicale d'intérêt sur la santé de la
femme avec tous les bénéfices qu'elle
peut en importer
voilà je vous remercie de l'avoir à
tanger un petit peu venu en exergue le
cas des gynécologues obstétriciens et
sur les chiffres je peux vous dire qu'en
2019 la france a compté une baisse de
plus de 8 % en huit ans des gynécologues
obstétriciens toutes spécialités
confondues au sein de cette spécialité
cette baisse globale s'est faite aux
dépens du nombre de spécialistes
médicaux euros les assurer le suivi
gynécologique des femmes tout au long de
leur vie
comment on a dit la dernière
intervention la précédente intervention
et qu'il est aujourd'hui en france d'une
densité de troy davis est gynécologues
médicaux ont cent mille images de
consulter en revanche le nombre de
gynécologues obstétriciens qui au fond
laissant spécialisé dans les actes
chirurgicaux comme la cheville gauche
manqueront au crès avec une hausse de
36%
malheureusement la baisse du nombre de
gynécologues médicaux va se poursuivre
dans les années qui vont venir est en
revanche à oran en raison des départs en
retraite puisque le nombre de jeunes
diplômés ne permettra pas de compenser
alors aujourd'hui l'âge moyen des
spéciales médicaux et de 65 ans et on
compte seulement 82 postes qui ont été
ouverts aux austin pour la rentrée 2010
effectivement tout cela va s'aggraver
quant aux inégalités territoriales de
leurs installations
on peut dire que l'accès des femmes aux
jeunes écolos de l'équipe très
inégalitaire selon les départements
avec 89 départements sur 101 qui compte
moins d'intensité que quelques dont je
vous ai parlé de 3000 cette gynécologue
pour 100000 habitants dont 26
départements
au moins la gynécologue médical pour
cent mille et l'ardèche par exemple ou
totalement dépourvu ces difficultés
d'accès à ces soins touche aussi bien
les campagnes que les villes et viennent
bien souvent s'agréger à d'autres
fragilité territoriales comme un accès
difficile aux services publics aux
commerces et même à une couverture
numérique
mais ce que ce qui est pas important les
départements hôpital universitaire comme
paris bien sûr la gironde aussi et là où
garde toutefois alors que nombre de
gynécologues obstétriciens cette fois
augmente les inégalités territoriales en
termes de services hospitaliers peuvent
également affecter les actes auxquels se
consacre ce spécialiste
ainsi selon la drees la france
métropolitaine comptait 1369 maternité
en 1975 contre 518 en 2014 si les
fermetures de maternités sont un facteur
supplémentaire d'inégalité dans l'accès
aux soins
une patiente notamment construit
grossesse ou l'accès à l'ivg chez elles
sont pas nécessairement dû à l'absence
de gynécologues obstétriciens
la décision peut être lié à la
difficulté d'embaucher des anesthésistes
réanimateurs indispensable
d'autres professionnels de santé ou à
nombre d'accouchements jugé insuffisant
pour assurer la sécurité des patients
alors l'accès aux soins des femmes
j'ai fait quelques petits constat bien
évidemment tant à dire que les habitants
du rural vivent deux ans moi que ceux
des villes et que l'importance de la
proximité dans l'organisation save the
santé est extrêmement important avec un
éloignement rural qui joue partout et
qui donne la preuve des immigrés
territoriales en matière d'accès aux
soins
al'inverse ces zones de forte
consommation de soins hospitaliers
correspond souk exception aux zones
urbaines et écoulement de circulation
qu'il est au lit alors la cartographie
des données suggère évidemment qu'une
fille a une forte corrélation et chaque
chose d'inquiétant
là où il ya pas de médecins libéraux qui
dépistent détresse le patient à
l'hôpital
évidemment moins de patients dont yvan
perso tu es la femme selon les données
oms sont les suivantes la santé des
femmes et des filles elle est bien sûr
influencé par la différence du régime
qui sont liées au sexe aux gens aux
autres déterminants sociaux même si on
sait que les femmes et femmes vivent
plus longtemps que les hommes ont depuis
seize leurs espérances de 10 mondial à
l'année
c'était de 74 ans pour les femmes et de
68 ans comme zone les femmes connaissent
une morbidité plus important témoin
davantage qu un service de soin de santé
que les hommes en particulier et en
raison de la spécificité biologique avec
un besoin en sentiments productive et
maladies cardiovasculaires sont la
première cause de décès chez les femmes
amélie cancers ceux du col de l'utérus
et du sein sont plus fréquents et le
cancer du poumon est le plus meurtrier
la dépression que savoir est plus
fréquent chez les hommes que les femmes
et conduite auto apprécie vivement que
le suicide représente la deuxième cause
principale de décès chez les femmes
âgées de 15 à 29 ans au niveau mondial
en 2015
les facteurs sociaux sont également
importants parce qu'ils induisent des
comportements de santé tout en père en
est une plus grande proximité les deux
systèmes de soins elles perçoivent leur
santé de manière plus négative en
général que les hommes et des cartes
souvent des limitations fonctionnelles
vivent un plus grand nombre d'années
avec des incapacités sont plus souvent
en situation d'isolement et resta donc
marqué par des disparités et des
inégalités ainsi au cours de la vie une
femme sur trois dans le monde est
susceptible le col à des violences
physiques ou sexuelles
chaque jour environ 835 meurent de
causes évitables via la grossesse et
l'accouchement les femmes en particulier
les jeunes femmes âgées de 15 à 24 ans
représentent la majorité des personnes
vivant avec le vih
alors depuis plusieurs années évidemment
la pièce de la démographie médicale du
conseiller national met en ligne à
l'aggravation de ses difficultés d'accès
aux soins dans les territoires et la
filière gynécologie ne choque pas a su
très vite et avec une forte baisse du
nombre de praticiens libéraux dont le
rôle est d'assurer le suivi
gynécologique des femmes tout le monde
aura toutefois des impacts
organisationnels d'accès aux soins dans
l'exemple du parcours de soin a quitté à
la pj n'a pas hésité à poser quelques
constats indépendant du facteur
démographique médical donc noter le
changement de comportement chez les
femmes dans leur vie avec les
problématiques d'obésité de tabac
d'alcool de manque d'activité physique
ont bloqué les déclarations de grossesse
qui sont de plus en plus tardives les
difficultés psychosociales qui sont
moins vous paierez les difficultés
prochain des patients psychiatriques
les offres locales et les territoires
qui sont inégalement réparties et bien
évidemment l'attractivité du territoire
alors les sous
du scion le conseil national de l'ordre
montre bien par son la chasse que les
difficultés démographiques sont réels et
qu'il faut trouver des solutions
en attendant que l'on les professionnels
de santé rayonnante
alors le cnom afin d'y remédier apporté
de nombreuses compositions un cadre de
l'élaboration de la réforme du système
de santé en défendant notamment la
réforme des études médicales avec la
professionnalisation précoce des
médecins la mise en place d'une
organisation territoriale tenant compte
des spécificités locales et incluant
l'ensemble des acteurs
il prône également le développement de
l'attractivité de chaque territoire
solide amende
c'est comme pour tout lorsqu'il manque
de médecins nom de tous jusqu'à
l'absence de couverture nue qui devient
indispensable afin de pouvoir bénéficier
des moyens évolutif d'installation et
l'exercice
alors on peut parler du bus itinérant
évidemment l'ordre des médecins estiment
que c'est eux les teens pourrait
représenter les teams foraine et parce
qu'elle permet à un médecin sans avoir à
supporter le coût l'équipement de divers
lieux d'activités d'aller au devant de
la population dans une des mobiles
le conseil national il s'agit simplement
d'un outil qui doit pourtant s'intégrer
dans un projet de territoire et qui vont
être discutés organise au niveau local
en fonction de l'offre de soins
disponibles en concertation avec les
professionnels de santé du territoire et
dans l'intérêt du patient pour skier
delà de la mise en place puisqu'il
démonière d'organisation et des outils
évidemment l'épiné nous a fait exploser
la téléconsultation que le conseil
national estime que c'est un outil
évidemment entre le médecin et le
patient il faut pas confondre avec la
téléexpertise qui permet au médecin
d'avoir un habile experts avec les
confrères spécialistes à distance c'est
téléconsultation c'est aussi un outil
qui doit être porté également par un
médecin du territoire dont les
conditions de réalisation prise en
charge ainsi que les tarifs qu'ils en
quarts ont été définis doivent être
respectées le déploiement cet outil a
été fulgurant du continent liés à
l'épidémie et apporter énormément des
dalles accès au soin de les aujourd'hui
est à l'origine de dérives qui sont pas
pro difficile à contrôler avec notamment
le camp du site et autres places sont en
vente en l'accès des services et média
24 heures sur 24
donnant l aspect commercial à l'exercice
médical malgré les cas imposer son
utilisation et leur est extrêmement
léger non à cette bonne utilisation
pour ce qui est de 14 à g par le plan la
santé 2022 avec l'organisation de soins
dans un territoire il faut parler des
maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires qui
offre un exercice plus disciplinés dans
un même lieu d'exercice qui sont faits
rares contenant juridiques sont les
nouvelles formes de ce france de société
que sont les six à qui on t'a cahier des
charges qui sont à remplir pour finir
labellisation et un financement par la
rs il faut savoir que c'est l'aspect
comment les appels sont devenus
maintenant l'outil le travail plébiscité
par les jeunes contrition de santé pour
s'installer dans le territoire il faut
donc aider à les développer
deuxièmement ce qui est très important
c'est la maîtrise de ce stage on en
entend parler et vous faut savoir c'est
le vivier de l'installation en effet
lanterne l'externe qui vient en stage
souvent revient replacer et ses
remplacements sont souvent le sujet
d'une installation sur le médecin maître
de stage qui part en retraite
il faut donc développer cette maîtrise
de stage et c'était un investissement
qui est très important dans les
territoires ruraux avec les aides
financières ou logement des départements
de l'est par les départements et les
communes avec la mise en place de
permanences d'accueil et l'installation
entre tous les acteurs de son qe les
territoires et avec la coordination
entre ceci afin de développer de façon
spécifique aux particularités de leur
territoire une plus grande attractivité
exercice pour les professionnels de
santé
on peut évidemment par les décès pts et
les coordinations de parcours de santé
entre professionnels qui s'inscrivent
dans un maillage du territoire avec des
protocoles de coordination qui a été
proposée dans le projet de ma santé 2022
afin de promouvoir mine c'est pts en
france le conseil national est une
réunion avec la djs le 14 janvier 2021
et la vigie os nous a précisé que le
travail de recensement de ce cpte ce qui
est en cours et que aujourd'hui on
pouvait penser qu'il ya des 578 projet
de ces pts pot-aux-roses
c il y en a au moins 2000 qui sont en
cours d'élaboration
alors ce qu'il faut juste savoir c'est
gagnant pas de définition stricte cissé
pts ce ne sont pas des électeurs de
soins ce sont des des communautés
professionnelles territorial de santé
qui constitue un mode d'organisation à
la main des professionnels de santé qui
vise à renforcer en coordination dans un
cadre populationnelle soit leur
territoire et sa vision d'une prise en
charge plus intégré voilà voilà ce que
je pense le conseil national voulait
dire et bien évidemment à la disposition
de tous pour une concertation sur les
modalités d'exercice et d'une
modification pour que les femmes soient
mieux prises en charge et je vous
remercie de me cantonner à paris je vous
remercie docteur claire si ray et je
passe immédiatement la parole à
anne-marie cura et catherine linares
trappe et qui interviennent pour l'ordre
des sages-femmes à vous mesdames
bonjour à tous et à toutes
merci madame la présidente je voulais
tout d'abord aussi remercié la
délégation aux droits des femmes du
sénat pour l'organisation de cette table
ronde sur un sujet d'une importance
cruciale pour la santé des fins je suis
un arrêt cura donc président du conseil
de l'enam des tâches femme et j'ai
exercé en tant que tâchent femmes en
hôpital public en vend 40 ans dans un
monde où le droit des femmes songent à
gand qui nous devons tous et toutes être
mobilisés chaque jour pour la perfection
de céder ce combat historique est
toujours d'actualité pour défendre le
droit des femmes l'accès aux soins et la
liberté de disposer de leur corps
aujourd'hui garantir les droits sexuels
et reproductifs est indispensable à
l'autonomie des femmes et à leur
émancipation
ainsi qu'à l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
tout d'abord je reviendrai sur quelques
constats qui illustre les inégalités
territoriales de santé auxquels les
femmes sont confrontées
il s'agit de l'orthogénie comme l'a dit
le professeur nisand aussi donc en 2017
en france 78 5 % des ivg ont été
pratiquées en établissements
hospitaliers et plus de
9 % en cabinet libéral et environ 2,2
pour cent en centre de santé ou en
centres de planification et d'éducation
familiale
l'accès effectif ali vg dépend donc en
grande partie de la carte hospitalière
notamment dans les zones rurales
le haut conseil à l'égalité noté dans
son rapport de 2013 consacré à l'accès à
l'ivg et que les femmes ayant eu recours
à une ivg étaient en moyenne à 30
minutes de l'établissement de prise en
charge mais que ce chiffre masque est de
fortes disparités parmi les facteurs le
haut conseil souligne l impact des
restructurations hospitalières
la fermeture d'hôpitaux de proximité et
en particulier des maternités depuis les
années 70 le nombre des maternités a été
divisée par 3 de façon continue ainsi je
le rappelle il y avait 8 114 maternité
en 96 593 en 2005 et 512 en 2016 pour
conserver le maillage territorial de
l'offre de soins certaines maternités
ont été remplacés par des centre de
périnatalité de proximité
les structures ont aujourd'hui des
fonctionnement et des missions très
variées aussi une redéfinition une
restructuration de cette offre de soins
annoncé par le ministre est attendu est
indispensable
on assiste aujourd'hui à une raréfaction
de l'offre médicale et à des disparités
territoriales qui contraignent certaines
parturientes à parcourir de longues
distances pour accéder aux soins et en
amène d'autres à renoncer à leur suivi
gynécologique l'engagement maternité
avait été annoncé par l'ancien ministre
des solidarités de la santé pour
organiser des schémas de prise en charge
pour les parturientes qui résident qui
résident à plus de 45 minutes d'une
maternité
si aujourd'hui cet engagement a du mal à
prendre corps il doit devenir une
réalité dans chaque territoire
peu importe la distance avec la
maternité pour cela il doit être
construit par l'ensemble des acteurs du
territoire et être présent dans le
projet de territoire de santé
les sages femmes constitue une référence
de ce
hantée de la santé généphi génésique
pardon avec un champ d'action global et
des compétences adaptées au suivi des
femmes en bonne santé
les sages femmes accompagnent par
essence les femmes dans leur grossesse
qu'elle qu'en soit l'issue
mais la profession de sage-femme a lutté
pour suivre les évolutions et répondre
aux besoins des femmes dans le domaine
de la prévention et plus
particulièrement dans le domaine de la
santé génésique des femmes
les sages femmes assurent le suivi
gynécologique des femmes en bonne santé
et prescrivent la contraception depuis
la loi hpst de 2009
elle participe également aux côtés des
médecins et des gynécologues au
dépistage organisé du cancer du sein et
du col de l'utérus
depuis environ 6 7 ans
les sages femmes se sont véritablement
emparé de cette compétence en matière de
suivi gynécologique de prévention
auparavant elle rencontrait des
difficultés liées à l'invisibilité de la
profession dans ce domaine et au manque
de communication et d'information auprès
de la population sur leurs compétences
médicales
si les sages femmes sont les
professionnels du suivi physiologique de
la femme elles peuvent également
prescrire et pratiquer les ivg
médicamenteuses depuis la loi de santé
de janvier 2016 devront au quotidien
pour garantir l'accès à ce droit
c'est désormais un acteur incontournable
de la politique de santé publique et de
la promotion de la santé la démographie
des sages femmes a suivi le
développement de leurs compétences pour
répondre alors dû à la mutation de
l'offre de soins les chercheurs sont
devenus une véritable porte d'entrée des
femmes dans le système de soins liés à
la santé génésique le nombre de sages
femmes est en hausse constante et
parallèlement cette démocratie
cette démographie a également suivi le
virage ambulatoire du système de santé
les sages-femmes permettent d'assurer
aux femmes une offre de soins pérenne et
de remédier aux déserts médicaux
le nombre de sages femmes est ainsi en
augmentation constante depuis 50 ans si
on revient en 1974
nous étions huit mille sage femme est
aujourd'hui en 2021
24000 sages femmes en activité le
secteur libéral connaît une panne
dynamisme prononcer suivant en cela le
virage ambulatoire
il ya eu une première augmentation en
2000 à 2008 le nombre des sages femmes
libérales a crû de 6 7% par an en
moyenne
et depuis 2011 en 2011 il y avait trois
mille quatre cents 12h vin qui
exerçaient en libéral ou en exercice
mixte en 2018
elles sont plus du double c'est à dire
7065 s'achevant en 2025 il y as en 2021
pardon il y a plus d'une sage femme qui
est perçant libéral c'est à dire toi
soit 35% de la population et sur ces 35
% de sages femmes libérales il ya un
tiers qui ont un exercice mixte
hospitalier et libéral le virage
ambulant est une ambulatoire est une
opportunité de santé publique car il
permet de garantir une offre de soins
intenses aux femmes et de répondre à
leurs besoins grâce notamment au rôle
exercé par les sages-femmes dans ce cas
je rejoins un certain nombre de points
qui ont été évoquées par les autres
professionnels de santé bien sûr je vais
revenir un petit peu sur ce contexte de
la ruralité que je connais puisque
j'exerce aussi en milieu rural alors
bien sûr on note une désertification
médicale plus ou moins marqué selon
selon les zones
mais surtout une désertification de
spécialistes en lady les gynécos mais
aussi les pédiatres
quelquefois c'est une difficulté pour
les pour les jeunes mamans de retrouver
un pédiatre rapidement on a bien sûr
l'éloignement des centres hospitaliers
et aussi de sang de santé gratuits type
pme un problème de la mobilité de ces
femmes qui quelquefois selon l'âge n'ont
pas le permis de conduire ou du moins si
l on y lit a quelquefois un seul
véhicule dans la famille et ce véhicule
est utilisé par le conjoint pour aller
travailler et donc ces femmes se
retrouvent entre guillemets un petit peu
coincé avec une difficulté d'accès aux
soins parce qu'en plus nous n'avons pas
la facilité des transports en commun que
connaissent les les grandes villes alors
dans le rapport hubertine auclert
récemment il est il est noté qu'une
personne est considérée éloigné de ses
de santé proximité dès lors qu'elles
habitent à plus de 20 minutes de celui
ci et c'est souvent ce qu'on retrouve un
minima dans les dents les ruralité alors
le avantages du pharmacien c'est d'être
un acteur de santé de premier recours
d'être la porte d'entrée dans le système
de soins est notre objectif en tant que
pharmacien c'est de garantir l'accès au
soin d'assurer la continuité des offres
de soins et l'orienté le patient dans
son parcours de soins le pharmacien ne
peut pas tout prendre en charge porte
heureusement mais il est là aussi pour
savoir orienter ces femmes dans la
demande de dents dans une difficulté
d'orientation et de savoir vers qui les
adresser
selon le les urgences alors quelques
mots de démographie pharmaceutique
nous avons à peu près enfin plus de
20000 pharmacie installés en france on
compte trente deux officines pour cent
mille habitants
donc on peut dire qu'on n'a pas de
problèmes d'accès aux officines grâce à
une répartition homogène et ce maillage
territorial fait du pharmacien un acteur
spécifiques dans les territoires
éloignés
il faut noter que plus d'un tiers des
officines sont installés dans des
communes de moins de 5000 habitants est
en rapport delà de la direction de la
recherche d évaluation et statistiques
l'adresse montre que les pharmaciens
figurent parmi les professionnels de
santé les mieux réparties sur le
territoire national en 2018 trois
communes sur dix étaient dotées l'une ou
plusieurs pharmacies la distance en
moyenne à la pharmacie la plus proche
pour l'ensemble des communes et de 3 km
8 y compris les communes avec une
pharmacie et cette moyenne est de 5 km
s'il n'y a pas de pharmacie dans la
commune
90% des communes bénéficient d'une
pharmacie à moins de 7 kilomètres et 66%
à moins de 5 km pour information aussi
le nombre de laboratoires de biologie
médicale pour 100000 habitants et de 7,1
enfin je reviendrai pas dessus parce
qu'on a été très évoqué précédemment
il y a aussi une augmentation de l'
exercice coordonné en de travail
l'inter est en pleurer professionnelle
via les maisons de santé professionnel
ou laisser pts qui sont en augmentation
et on ne peut que se féliciter de ce de
ce nouveau moyen aussi de l'exercice
alors je reviendrai sur les périodes
charnières comme ça a été dit
précédemment où les besoins en santé des
femmes à différentes périodes de leur
vie et ses besoins pour lesquels les
pharmaciens sont fréquemment sollicités
si on commence à l'adolescence on a les
demandes sur les vaccinations notamment
la vaccination contre le papillomavirus
et la vaccination hpv que l'on doit
promouvoir la contraception d'urgence
pour lequel le pharmacien est très
sollicité la contraception régulière
aussi et puis l'information sur les
infections sexuellement transmissibles
parce que nos jeunes pensent que la
pilule les protège de tout or on se doit
de d'expliquer aussi toutes ces
infections sexuellement transmissibles
notamment sida hépatites en trop
j'avance en âge et la femme jeune avec
son suivi gynécologique la contraception
l'accompagnement des traitements de
stérilité pour lesquelles elles ont
besoin d'explications parce que ce sont
des traitements qui nécessite une grande
précision dans leurs dans leur suivi
l'accompagnement de suivi de grossesse
là on est aidé par les biologistes dans
l'est pour les examens obligatoires et
on a tout un travail d'explication dans
ces suivis de grossesse en ce qui
concerne la prévention
l'arrêt du tabac de l'alcool toute la
surveillance de l'automédication et les
pharmaciens ne peuvent que ceux-ci
s'enorgueillir on va dire du dossier
pharmaceutique qui est mis à disposition
actuellement nous avons plus de 38
millions de dossiers pharmaceutiques qui
sont actifs donc qui nous permettent
d'avoir une connaissance du traitement
qu'ils sont consommés par les patientes
accompagnement de des grossesses à
risque avec toute la discussion que nous
devons avoir avec nos patientes les
diabète gestationnel l'hypertension
artérielle par exemple l'accompagnement
sur la vaccination antigrippale de la
femme enceinte ou le problème de la
vague de l'alimentation et puis ensuite
nous avons tout ce qui compte
l'accouchement et le suivi de
périnatalité le suivi du post partum de
la mer de l'allaitement les questions
qui se posent allaitement au naturel
artificielle la contraception au post
accouchement
et puis le suivi du nourrisson
alimentation toutes les discussions et
les questionnements que nous avons
autour des 11 vaccin obligatoire chez
l'enfant pour lequel nous avons un rôle
à jouer et qu elles auront ensuite la
femme nature avec tout le suivi vous
l'avez dit de la prévention des cancers
nous nous faisons le relais du 2 octobre
rose et la prévention du cancer du sein
le cancer du col de l'utérus avec en
relais bien sûr les pharmaciens
biologistes et puis le suivi
gynécologique avec les traitements
hormonaux substitutifs et la prise en
charge de la ménopause la prévention de
l'ostéoporose voir la prévention des
chutes
pour tout ça les pharmaciens ont à leur
disposition des outils de communication
à type d' affiches ou à tête à types de
documents que l'on peut remettre à nos
patientes grâce aux 16 forment le comité
d'éducation sanitaire et sociale de la
pharmacie française qui est une
émanation de de l'ordre j'insiste
beaucoup sur ces documents qui ont une
importance et qui sont le témoin de
l'information des autorités de santé
parce que beaucoup de femmes entre
autres ont beaucoup d'informations sur
les réseaux sociaux sur les forums qui
sont très délétère dans le l'information
quelques le recevoir et nous devons
régulièrement lutter contre ces fausses
informations qu'elles reçoivent sur ces
réseaux alors pour conclure je dirais
que le pharmacien est un acteur procès
de proximité un acteur de premier
recours qui et les pharmaciens sont bien
réparties sur l'ensemble du territoire
nous avons une accessibilité 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7
nous sommes disponibles sans rendez vous
nous disposons pour la plupart des
espaces de confidentialité pour recevoir
nos patientes
nous avons de la chance parce que nous
avons la confiance aussi des patients
dans le pharmascience et c'est quand
même pas négligeable et nous avons un
contact fréquent avec des femmes malades
soit mais aussi des femmes bien
pourtant tu qui qui à tout moment
peuvent avoir besoin de renseignements
sur leur santé ou celle de leurs proches
l'intérêt du milieu rural et d'exercer
en milieu rural c'est que nous avons une
connaissance peut-être plus approfondie
qu'en ville sur les patientes mais aussi
leur milieu social sur la famille sur
les difficultés de vie quelquefois du
chômage
quelquefois des séparations des
naissances des décès et nous connaissons
peut-être beaucoup plus précisément ces
familles
nous connaissons les traitements qui
sont pris par ses patientes avec le
dossier pharmaceutique encore une fois
nous sommes impliqués beaucoup dans la
prévention primaire dans le dépistage
est encore une fois nous avons un rôle
dans l'orientation dans le système de
soins pour savoir vers qui oriente et
nos patientes vers des médecins vers des
systèmes d'urgence vers des sages-femmes
et je dois dire qu'à titre personnel je
suis ravi d'avoir des autour de moi des
sages-femmes en libéral parce que ça
nous nous aide beaucoup pour
l'orientation de ces femmes
je lisais le rôle social du pharmacien
qui est important alors on l'a évoqué
avec les violences faites aux femmes je
reviens pas dessus puisque ce forçat
fera l'objet bien sûr bientôt d'une
nouvelle audition nous sommes les relais
de messages de santé publique et nous
tenons beaucoup à être ce rôle est là
pour avoir des messages qu'ils soient
assurés de leur de leur importance et de
leur fiabilité
on le voit actuellement dans le lac au
vide avec beaucoup de messages qui sont
diffusés et le les professionnels de
santé se doivent être des relais
d'information d'importance et validées
selon les territoires des maisons de
santé pluriprofessionnelle décès pts qui
permettent les échanges
interprofessionnels de travailler en
collaboration avec des médecins avec des
sages femmes avec des infirmiers puisque
l'heure n'est plus à travailler chacun
en silo met vraiment en interpro et à
communiquer les uns avec les autres et
se travaille en maison de santé permet
depuis quelque temps la possibilité pour
les pharmaciens notamment de faire de la
dispensation son protocole alors c'est
très cadré mais pour certaines
pathologies comme la prise en charge de
la cystite chez la femme
ou de la varicelle chez l'enfant mais
cela dans le cadre d'un exercice
coordonné
cela a été dit aussi la possibilité de
télésoins de téléconsultation la
situation sanitaire qu'ovide a montré
que ça renforcer cette cet exercice sa
accélérée des dispositifs notamment
quand comme l'accès à l'ivg
médicamenteuse
alors est ce que c'est une méthodologie
à pérenniser sa pourrais ça pourrait
l'être on peut se poser la question
puisque ça a été quand même assez assez
utilisé je pense qu'il faut aussi que
l'on prône l'accès à la messagerie
sécurisée pour qu'on puisse communiquer
entre professionnels avec une messagerie
qui permettent d une sécurisation des
transmissions des données
donc pour pour l'avenir et l'exercice
pharmaceutique
on pourrait peut-être imaginer que nous
pourrions avoir des entretiens
pharmaceutique avec des patientes à
différents âges ou à différents un
moment charnière de la vie
l'adolescence le la nécessité d'une
contraception sheila chez la jeune fille
qui peut être demande trop souvent une
contraception d'urgence pour la
l'orienter dans le système de soins peut
être que le pharmacien pourrait proposer
en première intention
une contraception micro progestative en
attente de deux rendez-vous médical avec
une sage femme ou avec un médecin
peut-être étendre la vaccination par le
pharmacien à certains rappels de vaccins
chez l'adulte voir la vaccination hpv
est peut-être on pourrait imaginer que
ça fasse l'objet d'expérimentations dans
certains territoires pour voir comment
cela peut se passer en coordination avec
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
et pour terminer je dirai que le
l'objectif du pharmacien ces deux à
chaque fois d'avoir du bon sens et de
voir comment prendre en charge ces
patientes qui sont bien souvent vous
l'avez évoqué aussi dans la
méconnaissance de ce qu'elles peuvent
des professionnels qu'elles peuvent
consultés et il est vrai que beaucoup de
femmes ne savent pas qu'elles peuvent
s'adresser à une sage femme
on voit souvent côté sage femme comme
étant la personne que l'on va voir au
moment de l'accouchement mais ni avant
ni après et avec le rôle aussi de la
sage-femme dans le cocooning et la prise
en charge du nourrisson ou peut-être de
l'entourage notamment dans les cas de
vaccination d'arrêt de tabac etc
donc on a encore tous un point une
communication à faire en ce sens et dire
qu'on est tous ensemble pour une prise
en charge améliorée de de ces femmes qui
ont besoin qui ont besoin de nous et
encore plus en milieu rural je vous
remercie en matière de vie active avec
une féminisation croissante de la
profession agricole même si les femmes
ne représentent que 25 % des
agriculteurs soit une femme sur quatre
il reste beaucoup à faire en matière de
santé au travail de prévention des
risques professionnels
donc le détail des chiffres sera
également transmis à la délégation mais
nous avons constaté que les femmes
salariées agricoles étaient en 2016
davantage concernés par les tms avec 3,6
maladie pour mille affiliés contre 2,6
maladie chez les hommes elles sont en
revanche moins concernés par les
accidents du travail impliquant un arrêt
que les hommes y compris pour les
accidents graves
il faut dire que le matériel agricole et
parfois peu adapté au gabarit et à la
force des femmes donc celle ci
rencontrent ainsi plus de pénibilité
pour par exemple monter dans un tracteur
alors que les marches sont très hautes
ou les commandes très éloigné le port de
charges lourdes
c'est également une difficulté les sauts
manipuler des aliments l'alimentation
pour le bétail
et puis le travail de force bien sûr
avec la contention les réparations sans
compter la répétitivité des mouvements
comme par exemple la traite des vaches
carrément l'exposition aux vibrations ou
au bruit donc malgré ces écueils
rappelons que d'importants progrès ont
été réalisés ces 50 dernières années
pour améliorer l'ergonomie des outils et
des matériels agricoles permettant ainsi
une meilleure à
cessibilité des femmes à la profession
agricole et services santé sécurité au
travail des 15e et ça travaille
quotidiennement avec d'une part les
salariés les non salariés agricoles pour
diminuer les risques professionnels
mais d'autre part aussi avec les
concepteurs pour améliorer le confort du
singe de leurs outils
comment ensuite ne pas évoquer le congé
maternité des agricultrices dont la
durée minimale a été allongé de deux à
huit semaines
la fss 2019 avec la possibilité pour
celles qui le peuvent de se faire
remplacer de prétendre à des indemnités
alignés sous les indépendantes
c'est une promesse de campagne du
président de la république dont nous
pouvons nous féliciter puisqu'elle
permet d'améliorer la santé des femmes
et des enfants
à noter pour l'année 2010 9 991 non
salariés agricoles et tous 1063 salariés
ont été indemnisées au titre de la
maternité sur la maternité encore je
précise que le résume agricole contribue
pleinement dispositif prado qui mais qui
permet un retour à domicile avec
l'accompagnement d'une sage femme
entièrement prise en charge par la msa
j'ajoute également que les fonds des
seize d'action sanitaire et sociale des
cases et mesah financer séjours vacances
qui participent au mieux être des
familles en fait renforcé estime de soi
et donc l'amélioration de l'état de
santé parce que ces séjours apporte du
répit aux familles notamment aux femmes
avec l'allègement de la charge mentale
et parentales première chose évidemment
on connaît les deux problèmes n'a deux
problèmes d'abord on a un manque de
moyens et il faudrait très vite
éclaircir alors est-ce que ce white par
la loi peut-être le qui fait quoi
on a un problème de moyens on le sait on
a un problème de moyens humains on a un
problème de manque de professionnels de
santé on en connaît bien les les
les causes on écrase on diminue même le
numerus clausus les numerus clausus dans
les années 90 alors que dans cette même
période
la france va passer de 54 millions
d'habitants à 67 millions d'habitants
avec évidemment et quatrième âges qui
s'est développé un quatrième agent
milieu rural qui s'est énormément
développée qui vit plus longtemps et qui
évidemment est très exigeant en demande
de deux besoins de santé cet hymne des
difficultés des médecins généralistes en
milieu rural
sur le plan chronophage donc à un manque
de professionnels de santé ça chacun a
fait le constat
à moment donné
comment prend tant les décisions
politiques qui font que on va amender
retrouver le nombre de moon provincial
de santé suffisant le président de la
république a effectivement
fait supprimer le numerus clausus à la
fin du concours de première année de
médecine
c'est une bonne chose on imaginait le
nombre de d'étudiants en médecine motivé
qu'on a sacrifié avec le numerus clausus
entre 1981 et 2017
mais il n'ya pas que les étudiants en
médecine qu'il faut évidemment penser
fléché je pense aux aux étudiants en
kinésithérapie insuffisant insuffisant
et donc quand est ce qu'on décide d'en
bouger les les quota insuffisant aussi
le nombre d'orthophonistes est
aujourd'hui la réponse en orthophoniste
et la première réponse urgente après un
avc et donc il faut il encore se
s'interroger sur quel est le plan en
france pour que d'ici 2030 nous ayons
assez de professionnels de santé partout
moi je vous rejoins évidemment tout de
suite parce qu'il faut le dire à un
moment donné notre dodo de matinée je
rejoins bien évidemment le professeur
nisand sur le on va pas imposer
je crois que le pas de contraintes
d'installation
c'est évident ça m'est arrivé plusieurs
fois de prendre l'exemple vous ne pouvez
pas dire un jeune médecin d'aller
s'installer à romorantin dans l'entente
en six ans n'a pas envie il ne fera pas
son exercice professionnel aussi
sympathique soit la sologne de la façon
la plus adaptée possible par contre que
à un moment donné on plafonne des
installations et c'est le cas des
pharmacies depuis la loi de 1941 qu on
plafonne des installations par
département si c'est le niveau de
pertinence
je crois que ça peut être un des sujets
de réflexion que l'on que l'on peut
avoir sur
le nombre de professionnels de santé
qu'il faut par territoire à voir je vous
rappelle aussi quand même ce qu'on a
parlé des hôpitaux des centres
hospitaliers
ça vaudrait le coup d'ailleurs d'en
faire l'évaluation à un moment donné
dans la loi hôpital patients santé
territoires d'août 2009 si je me
souviens bien porté par mon excellente
consoeur roselyne bachelot il y a décrit
qu'elle une garantie d'avoir un centre
hospitalier à moins d'une heure de tout
habitant dans ce pays rien qu'on puisse
d'ailleurs le le vérifier alors manque
de moyens humains c'est certain manque
de moyens financiers
oui c'est là que ça fait le lien avec le
qui fait quoi parce que par exemple le
beaucoup d'initiatives de bus et moi je
salue ces initiatives qui ont parfois
été portés par des collectivités
parce qu'on sait très bien que les
agences régionales de santé maintenant
ne mette plus de moyens il n'y a plus de
consultation itinérante par exemple en
matière psy parce que les ars ont coupé
les vivres à un moment donné mais le qui
fait quoi
vous savez que en france la compétence
santé n'est pas distribuée on a un code
de santé publique
heureusement on est une autorité de
santé publique les ars il ya sans doute
beaucoup à dire sur les ars mais le
contrôle en l'exemple que je connais le
mieux
une inspection de la pharmacie et ne
peut dépendre que du napt rsa ne va pas
dépendre d'une collectivité
ce qu'on en a parlé beaucoup de
transferts de rs éventuellement vers les
conseils régionaux il ya quand même une
autorité de santé publique qui doit
rester un moment donné m de
l'organisation de santé en france mais
le qui fait quoi et malheureusement pas
défini en matière de santé est donc
temps que ça sera pas défini c'est qui
paye quoi toujours la même question
alors les communautés de communes ont
pris d'initiative sur des maisons de
santé pluridisciplinaires les
départements auprès des initiatives tant
mieux mais par exemple pour avoir porté
dans le département dont j'étais le
président encore il ya quelques semaines
un bus de consultation
bucco dentaire c'est le coup et 100000
euros rien dans le fonctionnement parce
que il faut effectivement un praticien
ça c'est certain du matériel ça c'est
certain mais il faut aussi un chauffeur
faut l'entretenir et donc c'est le
problème de la mobilité du milieu rural
c'est comment on amène l'offre de santé
l'accès aux soins
ça s'adresse ce sont nos priorités
s'était dit par quasiment tous les
intervenants l'offre de santé accès aux
soins partout alors on a des choses qui
fonctionnent on a un maillage qui
fonctionne et donc c'est peut-être là
dessus qu'il ya un certain nombre de
choses pour lequel on peut s'appuyer les
pmi les pmi alors ça on sait que les pmi
relève des conseils départementaux
moi je crois beaucoup au réseau des
sages-femmes et maïeuticien alors je
rajoute et maïeuticien ce que nous
sommes dans l'indignation égalité
hommes-femmes la merde et il y a
maintenant des hommes qui pratiquent
et donc je sais pas s'il l'ordre a
changé sa définitis et sa définition et
crs lors de sage-femme mais il ya aussi
des hommes qui pratiquent donc moi je
crois qu'il faut qu'on développe ce
réseau de sages-femmes et maïeuticien en
libéral parce que c'est une vraie chance
or on en voit peu sur le territoire et
on en fait je pense pas suffisamment la
promotion on a un outil qui est très
fort tout le cas là encore pardon de
prendre l'exemple que je connaisse mais
quand je préside le département de la
vienne en ce qui concerne des collèges
nous avions mis des infirmières partout
dans les collèges nous avons affaire à
la tranche en ce 15 ans et évidemment
c'est une branche particulière notamment
chez les collégiennes et là il faut
donner à dans les collèges partout sur
le territoire en hyper ruralité en
montagne parce qu'il ya des collèges par
tous les moyens d'avoir des portes
d'accès aux questions de santé et je
pense que dans les collèges des
infirmières il ya une confiance et une
proximité et une liberté de parole
là ça on a une vraie chance lui
pardon d'insister sur les pharmacies
sujet ou où je travaille toujours
depuis une trentaine d'années en milieu
rural mais on a un maillage des
pharmacies par la loi de 2,41
alors juste pour la petite histoire vous
savez qu'il n'y a que deux lois de il
n'y a que deux lois de l'état français
vichyste que nous condamner de touche
évidemment qui ont été maintenus c'est
celle qui permet les licences iv dans
les bistrots et celle des licences de
pharmacies
ça n'a aucun lien à part que nous
vendons de l'alcool dans les deux cas
mais cette loi-là a permis de maintenir
un réseau de d'officine partout même si
aujourd'hui des tentations d'écraser des
licences et là je crois qu'il faut
s'était d'ailleurs notre collègue marie
pier richer de deux l'un est intervenu
hier en question d'actualité
vous savez que quand une officine est
dépourvu de 2,2 de pharmaciens et bien
elle est automatiquement fermés et au
bout de 72 heures est salissant s'est
écrasé aujourd'hui et ça c'est un vrai
drame pour les territoires ruraux
parce qu'ils perdent sans doute le
dernier pont de santé qui existe
et là encore dans les propositions que
nous ferons parce que c'est un outil
utile à la salle outil utile pardon à la
santé des femmes ne jamais écraser une
licence de pharmacie toujours essayer de
trouver il faut que les pharmacies et
les moyens de d'être les acteurs de
santé que hot que dans la dispensation
des médicaments alors là encore c'est
évoquer une pièce de confidentialité une
pièce technique c'est essentiel
vaccination les capable de tout faire un
jour propos quand on se limite
aujourd'hui au vaccin grippe vacciner
évidemment un sujet sur lesquels
un pharmacien va pouvoir sans problème
démultiplie un certain nombre d'actes
pour apporter des réponses de santé
voilà les quelques sujets il ya la
question de la téléconsultation qui est
un vrai sujet moi je suis pas un
défenseur des télécabines parce que il
faut en main donné qu'il humains dans
dans un échange de souffrance ou de
problèmes de santé parce que des fois
évidemment à la discussion mais la
téléconsultation et qui est
pharmacien peut être formé une sage
femme peut être formé à metz 1 1 lecteur
d'échographes avec derrière à distance
grâce au numérique un spécialiste de
l'échographie qui peut guider et qui
peut apporter une réponse
voilà quelques quelques pistes mais il
faut se poser la question évidemment des
moyens et du qui fait quoi pour apporter
des réponses
pardon d'avoir été très long même un
président merci chers collègues
rapporteur alors voilà on a quelques
inscriptions si vous pouvez être
conscient également et poser des
questions extrêmement précises pour que
nos interlocuteurs puisse vous répondre
donc je vais passer la parole à marie
pierre monnier merci moi j'ai envie de
dire rapidement introduction que
différentes auditions que nous avons eu
aujourd'hui confiant toutes les craintes
que nous avons eu et je trouve que nous
avons une sacrée mission dans ce rapport
c'est vraiment d'alerté et d'être force
de proposition parce que force est de
constater à travers ce que nous avait
dit que les femmes ne bénéficient pas
d'équité de soins sur certains
territoires français et je trouve ça
très inquiétant on s'en doutait chacun
d'eux sur son territoire quand on est un
territoire rural
mais vous l'avez mis mise à jour et je
pense qu'il faut vraiment trouver des
solutions et je dirais rapidement parce
que vous l'avez démontré il ya des
conséquences graves sur la santé des
femmes
notre collègue vient d'évoquer le rôle
des pharmaciens c en est une de piste
moi j'ai envie de dire on est
parlementaire
il faut donner les moyens aux
professionnels de santé il faut donner
vraiment les moyens et je dirais c'est
presque aube élèves que cela se joue
c'est à dire projet de loi de finances
de la france pour que deux portes ou en
france on puisse se soigner et enfin je
trouve vraiment très alarmant les
constats que nous avons fait aujourd'hui
oui il ya des déserts médicaux on le
sait les médecins généralistes
spécialistes ne vont pas parfois dans
des rapports très gros quand le
professeur israël nisand disais tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait 90% de deux cas où
il faut plus de 45 minutes pour aller à
une maternité bien
lens c'est pas quand on habite paris
lyon marseille et ça va être toujours là
encore des territoires ruraux et pereiro
qui vont être stigmatisés moi je crois
que ce qui ressort des auditions c'est
qu'il faut aller vers les femmes
il faut donner une information aux
femmes quand j'entends qu'elle ne savait
encore pas vraiment tout ce qui peut y
avoir à faire en termes de prévention
mais je trouve que c'est très grave
aujourd'hui que la situation soit comme
ça en 2021 donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment arriver à ce que oui il informe
assurer là et vous avez parlé de bus il
faut se déplacer parce que s'il sort des
auditions et il faut qu'ils aient des
médecins qui est auprès des femmes vous
avez parlé de bus le professeur ismaël a
parlé de deux centres prénatal de
proximité d'autres ont dit qu'il fallait
inciter les médecins moi je serai
coercitives parfois et j'estime que un
médecin qui a passé dix ans à faire des
études payées par l'état pourrait passer
trois années dans ses premières années
d'installation on l'obligé à aller dans
des territoires qui sont sous dotées où
il n'y a pas d'offre de soins voilà je
le dis à demain parce que je les
soutenir l'occasion de différents textes
ceci dit je veux pas monopoliser la
parole parce que je suis sûr que
d'autres ont d'autres choses à dire je
voudrais revenir sur deux trois choses
d'abord en drôme nous avons une
multiplication de contrats locaux conclu
entre la grèce et les collectivités
territoriales les collectivités
territoriales à partir d'un diagnostic
établi de façon concertée
ils apparaissent comme de bons outils
pour coordonner davantage les
interventions des différents acteurs
locaux de santé sur le territoire et
apporter des réponses au plus près du
terrain pour les problématiques
spécifiques qui se porte qui se pose par
exemple concernant la prise en charge
des femmes rencontrées dans certains
territoires notamment ruraux
est-ce que vous avez déjà pour votre
part sollicité était sollicité dans ce
cadre et si oui quel est votre retour
d'expérience un petit clin d'oeil à mon
collègue pharmaciens également qui a et
à ceux qui ont et qu'ils ont parlé de ce
que faisait les pharmaciens manger
récemment participé à une opération avec
les gendarmes sur la remise de sachets
de pharmacie sur lesquelles sont
inscrits les numéros d'urgence que les
femmes peuvent solliciter
de violence et c'est vrai qu'ils ont un
rôle important aussi
et puis ça a été brièvement abordé mais
peut-être pas vraiment santé mentale
dont la prise en charge là aussi ne doit
pas s'arrêter aux portes des villes et
le ms a constaté que les femmes étaient
plus susceptibles de souffrir de
dépression que les hommes ça a été un
petit peu abordée mais considérez vous à
votre échelle que c'est peut-être
dimension la santé suffisamment prises
en compte dans la réflexion générale sur
les déserts médicaux et en zone rurale
voilà c'était les trois points et je
veux pas être trop longue pour que mes
collègues et le temps de parler merci de
rebondir et sur deux points en
particulier si si vous me le permettez
le premier concernant l'encouragement de
l'installation des modèles de type
maisons pluridisciplinaires ou centres
de santé nous trouvons que les deux
modèles sont intéressants et qu'il
faudrait vraiment pouvoir avait
développé notamment en zone rurale
pourquoi parce qu'ils permettent cet
exercice pluridisciplinaire et qu'il
permette une offre de santé intégrés
dans un seul lieu
on c'est une offre médico social les
personnes se déplacent sont des
structures de proximité
elles permettent de développer un petit
peu plus relax prévention et on l'a
relevé il est extrêmement manquant pour
les personnes en situation d'exclusion
dans les zones rurales
mais il est vrai qu'il faudrait pouvoir
aussi interrogés n'ont semble-t-il dans
les maisons pluridisciplinaires les
modes de rémunération des professionnels
de santé
quand il s'agit de personnes en
situation de précarité c'était ma
première marque la seconde concerne la
santé mentale
donc effectivement un médecin du monde
dans tout dans tout le territoire
d'intervention que ce soit de l'urbain
entreprendre rural en outre-mer en
métropole ce sont des toujours une
thématique saillantes ya effectivement
de gros de deux gros chose à combler en
matière de santé mentale sur le
territoire français nos réflexions
aujourd'hui je vous disais nous sommes
en train de mener dans le plein par des
combats une mission exploratoire sur la
santé mentale mais grosso modo
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de tout
d'abord de réfléchir à définir les
professionnels en fait qu interviennent
en santé mentale c'est beaucoup de
cicatrisation du champ de la santé
mentale mais il faudrait interroger les
pratiques bon vous l'avez dit des
psychologues également le rhône
un généraliste qui sont la porte
d'entrée sur le système et pas qu'eux
donc leur type de dépistage
d'intervention en matière de santé
mentale
il y a également ce que nous faisons
dans certains territoires en france mais
à l'international
il ya aussi le chantre du soutien
psychosocial il va au delà des
professions médicales et qui peut être
extrêmement utile justement pour lutter
contre tous les phénomènes enfin de
souffrance psychologique ils sont lus et
ils sont liées à l'exclusion ou à la
pauvreté et peut-être aussi c'est l'état
de réflexion actuelle de réfléchir au
modèle communautaire en santé mentale
donc avec l'intervention de personne
dans la communauté dont les compétences
en soutien psychosocial serait renforcée
voilà pour moi et je vous remercie
merci docteur qui souhaitent prendre la
parole pour répondre aux questions aux
interventions s'il vous plaît oui alessi
alors je ne vois pas très bien je crois
que ça marche très bien
les deux auteurs avouent docteur des
petites interventions pour confier
négativement que les témoignages des
infirmières mambety dans notre audition
parce qu'effectivement elles ont un
grand rôle dans la coordination la prise
en charge des patients et notamment en
matière de prévention de soi et de
vaccination et effectivement ils
n'étaient pas intéressants probablement
d'avoir leur témoignage la deuxième
chose vous allez vous parler on en a
beaucoup parlé c'est pas toujours accès
à ce niveau c'est l'obligation à
l'installation
je fais partie parole du procès national
de l'ordre des médecins qui est
favorable à cette obligation
d'installation
les raisons sont toujours les mêmes ça
ne marche pas été mis en place et
aujourd'hui on peut même penser que
maillage des territoires à la mise en
place de celle s p qui est fait sous
l'égide des ars qui promet ce qu'elle
est équipée territoire et qui sont en
mesure de proposer de ne pas accepter la
mise en place du mail msp quelque chose
qui de fait a tendance à aller
partir les médecins sur le territoire
quand on sait que c'est maintenant la
seule façon les olsson professions de
santé ont envie d'aller travailler dans
les territoires il s'agit pas maintenant
de remettre des 1500 aide tout seul dans
une situation ne pourrait pas apporter
une offre de soins de qualité
il s'agit bien de mettre en place dix
endroits où les professionnels de santé
peuvent travailler en confort et
sérénité
entouré par des pairs et avec des
coordinations bien en place vous savez
que le compagnonnage reste la seule
enfant unique motivation
les professionnels de santé pour
s'installer et je crois qu'il faut là là
là continuez et dans la mise en place de
celle de 6 pts en est complètement dans
ce profil là et je crois
qu'effectivement une fois insister
dessus plutôt que sur les obligations
d'installation voilà je voudrais juste
dire un mot aux médecins généralistes
c'est que ne pas oublier que ils ne
peuvent pas se substituer à tout le
monde et qu'il faut leur redonner du
temps médical qui aujourd'hui leur
manque cruellement de temps que nos
confrères sont moins nombreux écrits par
le fonds des territoires ils doivent
assumer de plus en plus de charges
médicales
voilà je quant à la demande peu par
rapport aux mesures fiscales chine je
n'ai pas bien compris la question et je
vais bien qu'il a reprise pour fischbach
monte parce qu'effectivement on n'a pas
du tout fait d'études à ce sujet
[Musique]